hi how are you i am well thank you for
talking to me these characters are
always so fun to watch and it's it's
always so fun to watch this world
because i don't have to live in it
because it just seems like it would be
you know you'd be risking your life on a
daily basis yeah be difficult
could you ever have imagined that you
would be
saying huzzah so many times in one job
and is there anyone that keeps a running
counter for how many times you guys have
to say this
oh i wish someone i think
you wish there was so much job it was
just it was just just
a tally just that's it
a big chalkboard in the corner of the
studio
yeah that would be fun buildings
um gosh no i don't think i really could
have ever dreamed of a role
so great or a job so amazing with a
script like this and i i couldn't it's
kind of out of your
capacity of dreaming that up like things
like this
just
happen and i think they're meant to and
they come to you and it's very
instinctual and right and it's just
everything about this is so
harmonious and right there's we the cast
we love each other so much
everyone's like beyond talented like
in front of the camera behind the camera
just like
it's the most fun
show ever i vote that we i'm like out of
any show i think we have the best set i
really do i would bet on that
these characters are so big and bold and
over the top do you miss playing them in
between seasons or is it a character
that you're happy to pack away and take
a break from for a little bit
it's really it you know what it's
overall really really fun and it's not
because it's so well written and such a
joy to play them it's not taxing like
obviously there's times where it's
difficult and and takes a lot uh in a
really fun way that's
um enjoyable but so it's it's not
i do kind of miss i kind of miss i kind
of miss the process and what the
environment is and yeah you know not
saying that i'm like oh i want to be
like that character all the time but at
the same time
that world to inhabit it is is a
wonderful place to get to kind of go and
play so it's um i do miss it but yeah
yeah i do i miss the freedom like in a
way that our that we have
that we can kind of push the limits and
we can kind of do anything and that's
not that's like very rare i think the
movie so i feel that way at least this
especially it opened up i think this
second season everyone was really like
there to play
and um
it was it was just so fun
i don't know it was like so boring fun
such a boring word to describe such a
show like this but
it is i do miss it i'm on another job
now that is great
but i'm like and you hate it no you're
miserable because it's not there but
it's like i'm not there
but it's like the
it's it's so different i'm like i miss
catherine i really do i've never had
that with a character or what normally
i'm like oh that's good that's done you
know fine and that was a good experience
but i i genuinely actually do and i
think of things often of like
what i things i could do
in the show is her weirdly
like i could do that next season or
whatever
there seems to be a real
theme of slapping this season
what's it like to do a scene where you
have to slap yourself and i mean you
have to do that multiple times this
season and you're slapping other people
and you're getting slapped and i mean
what is it like to do all of that i know
i kind of loved it
well there was a stunt coordinator on
set and i it's like catherine has this
thing that she punches herself every
time
she gets emotional especially or gets
overwhelmed or she's thinking about leo
kind of like choked down her emotions
and i would
i don't know just like put my rings on
the other hand and haul off and punch
myself in the face and then the the
stunt coordinator was just like oh my
god like you can't do that like no no do
it fake and i was like it can't be fake
like it's on camp like
it's fine
something i don't know about it i always
we always try to do a real slap in the
tape if we're with other people i think
in the first in the pilot i accidentally
slapped you there was a take one yeah
[Music]
um but yeah i did and then we always try
to do one we're not doing it over and
over again i mean there's at least one
or two things there's one
yeah
they'll be like with belinda i would
she's like please just slap me like
let's do it and like please just please
and we just do so
we at least have one real one
because how weird is it for you to have
all of the look-alikes around set
because some of them really do look a
lot like you
would you have them for chickens there
was one that really looks like me which
is bizarre um it's a it's a really fun
uh
storyline that tony came up with of
these and it is actually kind of
strangely based on truth that the
valerie pugh this guy
uh did actually kind of
mount uh kind of tried to take the
throne from catherine because
i guess he's like he somewhat resembled
peter from like paintings
and he just kind of went with it and was
like yeah i am him and then got
supporters and kind of tried to
kind of try to a military takeover sort
of thing so it's um it's a fun kind of
based on truth there was a lot of tall
broad
dash guys
i was in my element i was looking at
them and i was like this is it i've made
it finally um that was it was funny
because also it's like
sunny there's like bits of peter's
costume bits of pooka joe's costume and
also it's just funny because
there's this
idea that peter has of the
that catherine would never kill him and
and it's clearly put
um false because the second he sends
most look-alikes out they get shot right
immediately
she kind of
she has she knows it's not you
instinctually maybe i don't know she can
tell people that yes
well these two are left in quite an
interesting place by the end of the
season
what would you say about
their
state of mind and how that could affect
things
into season three it's gonna be
interesting i don't know i mean it's
like i can't there's a lot of things we
can't say i really
i really want to know what tony's gonna
write
because you know if we get to do that
it's kind of left a spot where i don't
think either
in a lot of different ways could know
how to move forward that's right i think
that's what happens in a lot of
relationships anyways like there starts
to be so much history in life and
baggage for lack of a better term that
it's very difficult to see a future and
i think that's what starts to happen to
catherine and peter you know there's
obviously throughout these first two
seasons a lot of love and admiration and
wonderful things between them but also
truly horrendous stuff as well and
they're now parenting together but
um
there's a lot of truth
of what she's tried to do to him and
what he has done to her that
you can't
move past
overall perhaps
but i mean catherine has moved past a
lot
with him given a lot i've forgiven a lot
so
maybe
i don't know i don't know if
we'll see
i don't know i'm interested
i love the little moment between the two
of you in episode five where you're
dancing together without music in the
bedroom there's just something so sweet
about that moment between them it feels
like there isn't any manipulation
involved like there often is
is was that a fun moment to shoot when
you have all this chaos going on and
these two people who always want to kill
each other is it nice to just have a
sweet moment between them
yeah it's really nice we also um i love
when we get to do the dancing in the
show because they're always like kind of
these odd little funky dances that we
get to learn
um
normally at the end of long shoot days
they're like can you go in one of the
sets and just
learn this dance real quick we're like
oh okay
learn it quickly and do it but that's
such a i know that it's at the end of
that episode and i think that's a lot
that's a big that's kind of well yeah
halfway in the season i think it's a
turning point for
catherine i mean she's obviously really
trying to suppress
how she's feeling or she's actually kind
of confused she's like how am i really
feeling about this guy like i thought i
hated him i want to kill him and i'm
like i kind of like dancing with him so
like what does that mean um and
yeah
that was that was sweet it's nice to
honestly also have
scenes where we don't have to say
anything
or memorize any lines so to have like
quiet moments like that where you can
just
i don't know show it's just in the eyes
it's quite quite moments ago because
it's also the scripts and the show is
also
always so dialogue heavy
and sharp and
with that so when you do get a moment of
peace or silence or just characters
being together and enjoying each other's
company without
the back and forth and kind of
that side of things it's i think it's
very powerful for that um
yeah
it also feels like on this show if you
forget a line you could just swear and
then it'll work because
i mean that's how these characters are
anyway
i know i think it's very specific to
swearing it's very tony puts it in at
very specific moments it's delicate you
know peppered in
but all very thought through
yeah
oh you have
multiple emotional breakdowns on this
show this season what are those scenes
like for you to do do you have any
specific preparation or any tricks that
you do in those moments
i mean i don't know i think it's
something that's
i don't know you kind of i mean you have
to like
okay like my family's like very sports
like everyone's in sports
so i kind of look at acting similarly to
a sport
and it's like you have to get in
whatever zone it is to like all right
it's game day or like it's time you use
the anxiety or the nerves and like use
that to kind of get you
so riled up
that you kind of it just explode
and i like that feeling of like
teetering on the edge to finally be like
okay boom i don't know it's something
about it
it's hard to describe weird things like
that but um
yeah it's kind of cathartic
and catherine
i think those moments are really can be
really shocking in the show too when
it's like the emotional punch
um
because
i think that this show works
well because it's funny but it also
really has you know it has the heart too
and people we hope they care
well thank you guys for talking to me
about it you are both absolutely
brilliant in these characters so i hope
we get lots more of them
thank you very much
you